لفهم حسني مبارك ،
عليك أن تبدأ من هنا مع
سلفه ، وفي حين أن السادات الذي وقع في عام 1979 على
اتفاقية كامب ديفيد للسلام مع
إسرائيل ، فإن تلك المصافحة في
حديقة البيت الأبيض أثارت غضب المتطرفين المسلمين الذين
اعتقدوا أن السادات قد باع المصالح العربية في
جميع أنحاء المنطقة احتجاجًا على
الكثير.  قطعت الحكومات العربية الوسطية
العلاقات الدبلوماسية مع مصر بعد
عامين ونصف بينما
كان الرئيس السادات يراجع عرضًا عسكريًا مع
نائب الرئيس آنذاك حسني مبارك الذي كان
يجلس بجانبه متطرفون إسلاميون
في الجيش كان انتقامهم اغتيل السادات
جريحًا لكنه نجا حتى يؤدي اليمين.
في منصب الرئيس الذي كان في أكتوبر 1981 ،
نشأ مبارك في دلتا النيل
وتخرج من أكاديمية القوات الجوية
المصرية وترقى بسرعة في
الرتب عندما دخلت مصر وإسرائيل الحرب
في عام 1973 ، كان قائدًا للقوات الجوية
جعلته براعته العسكرية
بطلاً قومياً عندما  وصل إلى السلطة كانت مصر
منبوذة من العالم العربي لتوقيعها
اتفاق السلام الذي ذهب إليه مبارك  فيما يتعلق
بالهجوم الدبلوماسي الذي يحسن بسرعة
العلاقات مع جيرانه العرب ، فهو
يعتبر أن السلام لا يوجد شيء
مستحيل ، فالشينوبي فقط للناس
هنا للإنسان منذ ما يقرب من 30 عامًا
كان مبارك ضيفًا منتظمًا
للرؤساء الأمريكيين وكان حليفًا للغرب في
الجهود.  لاحتواء القاعدة وتعاون مبارك
في جهود أمريكية متكررة
للتوسط في صفقات سلام بين إسرائيل
والفلسطينيين هنا مع الرئيس
رونالد ريغان
لا يمكن إنكار ممارسة حق تقرير المصير
للشعب الفلسطيني
في الوطن في مصر
رغم أنه كان  مسألة أخرى
تم التأكيد على رئاسة مبارك
ثلاث مرات في التصويت الوطني ولكن بموجب
القانون لم يُسمح لأي شخص آخر
بالتصويت بعد ضغوط أمريكية أجريت انتخابات يفترض أنها
مفتوحة في عام 2005 حيث
اشتكى المراقبون الدوليون من أن
الاقتراع تم تزويره
بعد الطعن في نتائج الانتخابات.
تم القبض على صاحب المركز الثاني في التصويت
بتهمة التزوير وحكم عليه
خمس سنوات من الأشغال الشاقة التي أدت إلى أن العقوبة
سببت توبيخًا قويًا من البيت الأبيض
لحكومة مبارك ، حيث ألمحت حكومة مبارك البديلة إلى
أنها فوضى ، وكان تاريخ مصر المؤلم من
الهجمات الإرهابية يعني أنه لم يُترك سوى القليل
للخيال من الأقصر في عام 1997 عندما كان
أكثر من 60 شخصًا معظمهم من السياح.
ذبح في مدينة
شرم الشيخ في عام 2005 حيث
قتل 88 شخصًا مثل قطة يبدو أن مبارك
قد عاش تسعة أرواح ، وقد نجا من عدة
محاولات اغتيال بما في ذلك
هجوم من قبل متطرفين إسلاميين على
موكبه خلال زيارة إلى إثيوبيا عام 1995
عندما جاء مبارك  إلى السلطة في
عام 1981 ورث دولة
مزقتها الخلافات الاقتصادية والسياسية.
أراد المثاليون الإسلاميون والمتطرفون
دولة إسلامية.
يسمح للصحف
بنشر مقالات تنتقد
الحكومة و  جلبت الإصلاحات
الاقتصادية نموًا اقتصاديًا قويًا ، لكن هذه
المقابلة من عام 1981 قد تقدم تلميحًا
إلى مقاربتي الحذرة للتغيير
في ثكناتي.
ثورة مصر 2011 عندما
أُجبر على ترك منصبه ،
تخلى أخيرًا عن سيطرته الطويلة
على الشعب المصري. كانت
الثورة لحظة حاسمة ليس
فقط لمصر ولكن للعالم العربي
[تصفيق]